Mr President nice to meet you it's a
great honor thank you so much thank you
for welcoming iom thank you so much we
see a spontaneous movement of return
from other oblasts to the oblasts of
origin so in turn internal displacement
and we see also returns spontaneous
returns from European countries back to
Ukraine
we anticipate that of course the winter
will have an impact in these movements
because it becomes much more difficult
to move during winter so when we speak
about cities we are speaking about
eating processes based on gas and on
electricity and any attempt and damage
and of those facilities will have a
terrible impact in the capacity to eat
the cities
and we are doing all our efforts to
assist the populations
in preparing for the winter but we need
the electricity and we that depends on
the state services to put back working
the electricity we have seen in the
Press
several reports about
ukrainians that have been sent to Russia
but we do not have access we do not have
access to the Russian side of the Border
and therefore we cannot confirm figures
we know just what are the figures that
have been public made publicly available
by the ministry of Defense of Russia and
I can tell you that from the many tens
of thousands of phone calls that our
outline had 62 percent of them were
women
and precisely those 62 percent always
focused on what can I do to bring to
prevent being
prone to traveling so traffic has always
figured very high